faire participer les habitants à la
politique de la commune c'est l'objectif
de ces conseils de quartier poser des
questions proposer des idées donner son
avis les cogner rien sont invités à
s'exprimer sur tous les sujets
concernant leur quartier c'était
l'occasion de poser les questions en
direct au maire de parler des sujets qui
nous préoccupent en donc citoyens
échanges et parler des problèmes font
avancer
l'état du quartier les conseils de
quartier une promesse de campagne de
didier fischer mise en place depuis son
élection le maire a décidé d'accorder
une enveloppe de 30 mille euros pour
concrétiser les projets proposés
ça peut être un aménagement j'ai pas de
passage pour piétons ça peut être un
aménagement des bacs à fleurs ça peut
être de l'éclairage voyez il ya ça peut
être tout d'une certaine façon n'est
pour l'instant rien n'est défini un
et c'est en fonction des besoins en
effet du quartier c'est essentiellement
un rôle d'écouté
c'est une première prise de parole
c'était la première premier conseil de
quartier sur ce secteur donc c'est une
découverte pour tout le monde
je pense que le prochain sera un petit
peu plus aboutie et qu'on pourra
apporter vraiment des réponses aux
poignets rien coignard est découpé en
quatre quartiers les réunions seront
prévues chaque trimestre elles feront
l'objet d'un compte rendu mis en ligne
sur le site de la ville